more than one million people have been
displaced because of the storm some
residents are now returning home but
others could continue to face even more
flooding michelle miller is in houston
with the latest michelle good morning
good morning well places that have dried
out the desperate cleanup begins here in
meirland texas block after block there
are piles of debris and sheetrock and
waterlogged furniture that have been
pulled out of these flooded homes the
smell of mold and mildew is overwhelming
and this is progress a lot of people
aren't even here yet
a week after hurricane harvey made
landfall flood waters in many parts of
houston are still receding
i don't know how i could ever repay you
don't have to residents like howard
holmes are relying on the kindness of
strangers 90 percent of this block is in
survival mode right now it's heart
wrenching some houstonians face more
flooding when the city begins releasing
water from two reservoirs on friday the
city's mayor sylvester turner implored
people to leave now if they can to
remain in your homes for the next 10 to
15 days is simply
is simply not in your best interest
and neither is it in the best interest
of our first responders but there are
signs that life is moving on we had one
store flood out in maryland mattress one
manager don ice is helping the community
get a fresh start i've had
a lot of customers that have lost
everything they've had and are moving
into apartments and this is the first
thing they have to have is a new bed to
sleep on but about an hour south of
houston in lake jackson mario martinez
was just seeing the waters rise for the
first time we were waiting for water to
come in but i never thought this
neighborhood would get it we thought we
were high and dry right here runoff from
the brazos river is forcing residents to
flee we stacked
two sandbags
high around each of the doors all the
way around the house al baird and his
wife sherry found safe harbor for their
horse and grabbed their dog before
fleeing to a friends for what could be
an extended stay
people don't realize it's a beautiful
day outside and then how hard it is to
watch this water rise not to have any
control
i think that's the hardest part is that
there's nothing you can do
and while so many people are still
dealing are still dealing with all that
water a hundred and twenty four thousand
homes remain without power anthony well
michelle miller in houston thank you
michelle